hello everyone and welcome to a really
complicated game you will enjoy
immensely yeah it's uh from the match
ukraine versus norway that we covered a
few days ago but this is the one game
that eluded us and even though a lot of
you guys have requested it but now let's
uh check it out as it does deserve to be
shown uh it's magnus with the white
pieces against the ukrainian grandmaster
20 year old kiroshvchenko like i said
brutal game uh let's uh let's dive
straight into it so magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with d4
we have knight to f6 c4 and now c6 going
for the sort of a slav indian defense
combo uh bishop to f4 by magnus and now
queen to b6 so not really a london
system but uh this could be considered
somewhat of a
defense to the london system uh so it's
uh it's a very interesting one it uh
brings the queen out into the game early
and you're already putting pressure on
that b2 uh uh b2 pawn so magnus
defensive queen to d2 and then now
knights to e4 attacking the queen here
queen to c2 and now d5 uh we have e3 now
and here comes bishop to f5 now
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries uh and here uh there is a
game where queen to b3 was played that
just offers a queen trade but here we
have bishop to d3 and it is now as of
move seven that we have a completely new
game uh so let's see how uh black can uh
go about this so first d captures on c4
of course we want to get to the bishop
out of that b3 square uh bishop captures
an e4 and now bishop captures an e4
queen captures an e4 and queen captures
on b2 so here shivchenko is going after
the rook on a1 but not really as you'll
see so here bishop captures on b8 by
magnus and then now comes queen to c1
with check
if you play queen captures on a1 right
away then queen to c2 and everything is
perfectly fine black will have to play
c3 just to try and get the queen out of
the game as for the moment the queen is
pretty much stuck on a1 so instead after
this bishop captures on b8 we have queen
to c1 with chuck uh king the e2 this is
the only move for magnus and now comes
rook capture sun b8 and now we have
knight to f3
attacking the queen and pretty much
offering a full rook on h1 but if uh
black declines the rook for example if
some like queen to b2 we're just going
to continue developing and we are up a
full piece of course this will be
completely winning for magnus so here uh
shivchenko has to
accept this uh seemingly free gift but a
few things in in in life and in chess
are free especially when you're playing
against the magnus so here magnus uh
gives up the rook queen captures an h1
is played and now queen to e5 attacking
the rook on b8 we have rooked the d8 and
now uh the star move uh knight to e1 so
the queen on e5 uh who was played not
only to attack the rule but also to
guard the h2 pawn and now the knight on
e1 guards the g2 pawn and there is no
way for the black queen to get out of
that h1 square so uh what does this mean
for our game is the game over is magnus
just up a queen now how how
uh how can schweichenko go about this
position uh well he starts with h5 of
course uh he will not just resign he
wants to bring his rook into the game
and we've seen the game where uh
young pragernanda had his queen trapped
for pretty much the entire game and then
he ended up winning so of course you you
have to try knight to c3 now comes rook
to h6 and now rook to b1 magnus goes
after the b7 pawn so b6 defending and
now comes uh pawn to h3
and even though it seems like there's no
way for the black queen to get into the
game uh it was uh uh necessary to play
rook to d1 here uh because even though
the d4 pawn seems to be protected uh not
really as you'll see in the game so here
h3 was played and now the queen no
longer has to keep an eye on the h2
square now the g2 pawn defends the h3
pawn but you still need your queen on
this diagonal if you move your queen
away from this diagonal then black can
just play queen h2 and bring the queen
back into the game so here rook to e6
attacking carlson's queen and now queen
to c7 we still uh have to keep an eye on
that h2 square otherwise the black queen
just goes back into the game
g6 uh preparing to bring the bishop into
the game and now comes uh queen back to
g3 now to understand queen to g3 we
first have to uh see what happens if
magnus just plays rook to d1 and you can
see that there is no way for white to
put any pressure on the black king even
though the black queen is completely out
of the game uh black's plan is very
simple he's gonna play bishop to g7 and
now you don't really have a move with
white what are you gonna play
if you play something like rook to b1 we
can play c5 and now after something like
d5 okay you can attack the rook now the
rook comes to d6 and this is basically
what we uh wanted to have now uh the
queen no longer guards the h2 square we
can bring our queen into the game and we
don't really need to worry about
anything if knight comes to e4 we just
capture on d5 and then we completely
bust open the d file and then we are
completely winning so here magnus said
all right i can't play something like
that i have to go back queen to g3 i
really have to keep an eye on that h2
square but now i've pretty much given it
up for you but just in case uh
i haven't uh feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the absolute
winning idea
for uh shivchenko here while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that we
have to win this diagonal over for us
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show of course the move is h4
so congratulations to everyone who
spotted this uh in the game magnus
captured on h4 but uh other moves aren't
all that all that much better if you
play queen f4 we just continue with the
g5 and then of course if queen g4 we've
uh uh won the one the h file for
ourselves or queen captures on g5 for
that matter so there's no way to keep um
uh to keep control of this diagonal and
if queen back to c7 then is the very
simple let's so let's say we just move
the bishop and next whatever white plays
we're just gonna play queen to g1 and
now okay we have this insane pressure on
the on the e3 pawn we're just going to
start capturing and that's it there's no
way for whites to defend this so after
h4 magnus captured on h4 but now uh now
we have queen the h2 and the black queen
re-enters the game uh g3 magnus says but
not so quickly we're still going to keep
the queen on the h2 square but now
bishop to g7 uh we have knights to f3
attacking the queen queen to g2 uh and
here uh it seems like uh magnus has a
way of keeping the black queen on the
on the g2 square uh for example if
knight back to e1 uh how do you uh how
do you save the queen here if you go
queen h2 we just repeat knight f3 then
you go back we go back knight to a1 uh
if you go queen to g1 again we repeat
knight to f3 queen g2 and knight to the
e1 however
and that's why i said that the d4 pawn
was extremely weak even though it's
defended by the pawn and by the queen
there is rook captures on d4 and that's
why uh the repetition is not possible
now we're attacking carlsen's queen and
there is nothing
useful that white can do here we can
capture on d4 but now we just trade down
bishop captures on the e4 knight
captures on g2 bishop captures on c3 and
after rook to c1 we're going to move the
bishop let's say rook captures on c4
king d7 defend the c6 pawn one more time
and you get this end game where it's a
bishop against the knight black is up
one pawn but the game is completely
winning for black black has a past c
pawn and it's a three to one advantage
on the queen side uh also the bishop
can play on both sides of the board the
knight really can't and this will be um
this will be impossible to hold so
magnus of course spots this and he plays
queen to h7 but now uh here just rook to
f6 and he was in this position and move
23 that magnus carlsen resigned the game
and a wonderful wonderful victory for
kiril shivchenko uh who uh grabs a
valuable point for the for team ukraine
uh but since we already covered this
match you guys know that ukraine won
every match for for four rounds were
played and all four rounds were won by
ukraine uh i believe it was uh three to
one uh then two and a half one and a
half then again three to one then two
and a half one and a half or maybe not
in that order but those were the those
were the points and uh that they've won
by uh by a very nice margin but yeah
here after rook to f6 magnus resigned
and uh that's just it there's no way to
defend uh the knight is hanging if you
move the knight then the f2 pawn is
hanging and
even if you try giving up some material
we're just going to capture and after
let's say kink to e1 we're just going to
play king f8 defend our bishop and it's
i mean
there's just uh too much material for
black well white is down a whole rook
uh so yeah after rook to f6 magnus
resigned and a brilliant brilliant
victory for um uh 20 year old ukrainian
grand master kiroshenko who takes down
the world champion uh but
again just a very very very impressive
game uh i mean the the just uh this is
move like this is uh the bishop captures
on b8 is move 10 already on move 10
there's a rook hanging you can play
queen to c1 uh there is so much stuff
happening and then
this idea of just knight to f3 by magnus
it's a brilliant idea and uh maybe with
uh you know uh uh maybe with absolute
precise uh you know uh engine play maybe
you can hold this but uh shivchenko
proved that the queen was never really
trapped and it was only a matter of time
before the queen gets out of the cage
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it many of you have requested
this one so there you have it another
example of a trapped queen breaking free
uh i would like to thank uh uh michael
mcconnell nagarjuna ponogoti suresh k uh
paul hunnermund uh and michael calvera
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day